Sophia varara is Griselda Blanco in one
of her most terrifying roles since
Modern Family no woman is okay with this
and then when you Le suspect it we make
you pay are you as turned on as I am
right now from the guys who brought us
Naros and Naros Mexico comes the true
story of one of the most notorious
female narcos of all time but how much
of this story is actually true and how
much is as fake as Sophia's prosthetic
nose in this video we're going to take a
look at griselda's journey and
separating fact from fiction but before
we begin make sure to like And subscribe
and leave a comment about what you
thought of the show one of the things
the show glosses over is griselda's life
before becoming the drug kingpin of
Miami in fact Griselda was responsible
for establishing a complex network of
cocaine Roots between Colombia and big
US cities such as New York Miami and
California before the events of the show
even start in 1975 3 years before
Griselda takes place Griselda was
indicted on federal drug conspiracy
charges and thus she fled back to
Colombia where our Story begins the
writers decide to start griselda's
Journey at her lowest her once- thriving
drug operation with second husband
Alberto Bravo was bleeding money and in
order to erase this debt Alberto makes
Griselda a former prostitute sleep with
his brother while it is true that
Griselda shot and killed Alberto there
is no evidence to suggest she ever slept
with his brother it should be pointed
out that Alberto was griselda's second
husband and that her three children we
see at the start of the show are from
her first marriage to a man named
Charles trilo who is reported to have
also been killed by Griselda giving her
the nickname The Black Widow we should
also mention griselda's relationship
with Pablo Escobar the show starts with
a quote from him stating the only man I
was ever afraid of was a woman named
grisela Blanco while there is no
evidence to suggest he actually said
this it is very likely Griselda and
Escobar knew of each other in Hugo
Clark's book The Black Widow he claims
there are accounts that it was Griselda
who introduced Escobar to the cocaine
trade while other accounts say they were
vicious enemies both might be true after
the murder of her husband Alberto
Griselda takes her three kids to start a
new life in Miami not taking long to
establish her own drug Empire in the
show there's this whole scene where
Alberto's brother comes to take revenge
only for his bodyguard to save the day a
bodyguard who will eventually become
griselda's third husband Dario this
likely never happened as Dario and
Griselda were already married before
moving to Miami in fact their son who
they named Michael Corone after Al
Pacino's character in The Godfather was
not born in Miami as the show depicts
but in Colombia before they move
throughout the show Griselda encounters
many obstacles not only because the drug
world is inherently violent and
backstabbing but also because she is a
woman this turns out to be a weakness
and strength a weakness because none of
the other men want to do business with
her in fact when grazilda teams up with
Rafal Rodriguez AKA amalar only he is
allowed to conduct the deal with the
meden cartel they only accepted anything
if it came out of a man's mouth right
but being a woman also works to her
Advantage as several times throughout
the series these men underestimate
Griselda and just how cunning vicious
and violent she can be Johnny she's got
more balls than you do with amalar at
first unwilling to team up with the
woman even though her product is
superior Griselda starts dealing to the
untapped Market of rich white folk in
Miami Griselda ran a lingerie company
which she used to manufacture bras with
padded pouches that could store cocaine
but if she's going to make it to the big
leagues she's going to need to come up
with a new plan enter her man panesso
the two worked together for several
years building the Empire until
eventually as the show would have us
believe Gilda has him murdered although
according to the Miami dat Police
pesso's Murder has never been
successfully closed and Griselda was
never prosecuted for it the big shakeup
for Griselda comes when the medine
cartel offers to buy out her and all the
other dealers in Miami to establish a
monopoly over the city one in which they
can control the price of cocaine
according to the Daily Mail it's
estimated that at this time Griselda was
making up to $80 million a month so you
can see why she doesn't take the offer
eventually Griselda and mlc car team up
making a deal with the cartel for the
distribution of drugs in Miami but when
Amar is arrested in a shootout one which
actually happened Griselda is
backstabbed by all the other men and
left with nothing this is where we see
giselda at her most ruthless she
recruits her own Army of meritos
composed primarily of Cuban immigrants
and instigates a series of Ruthless
attacks against her Rivals killing
panesso and stealing dozens of shipments
this strategy proves successful as
eventually the Medan cartel makes her
the head of the Miami operation however
I could not find any evidence to suggest
that griselda's accountant Arturo was
killed in this meeting with Fabio Ooa 3
years pass and Griselda is at the top of
her game not to mention the richest
she's ever been it's estimated that at
her Peak she was worth somewhere from
1.5 to2 billion at the same time the DEA
established centac or Central tactical
program with the goal of taking down
major narcotics operations one such
member of this team was June Hawkins
she's based off a real Miami homicide
detective of the same name and her story
oddly mirrors that of grisela both are
divorced single mothers who moved to
Miami to care for their children fun
fact jun's partner Al here would later
become her husband like many in despotic
positions of power Griselda becomes
increasingly paranoid after one of her
drug stashes is discovered by the cops
leading her to believe that someone in
her ranks is an informant this paranoia
causes her to approve the murder of her
longtime bodyguard Chucho almost kill
her best friend and accuse her husband
of betraying her it's true that chucho's
son was killed in a driveby shooting
gone wrong but according to Max
Mermelstein who we see briefly in the
show Griselda was happy about this
because it would quote upset the father
griselda's paranoia reaches its peak at
her husband's birthday party where after
discovering her husband might be
cheating on her she makes some of the
guests strip and bark like a dog as much
as I would love this to be true I
couldn't find any evidence to support it
happening the event that's really the
nail and Grisel coffin is the death of
Marta Ooa in the show she's depicted as
Rafa Salazar's girlfriend but that isn't
true in fact Rafa left America in 1979
and thus wasn't even there to attempt
killing grisela as the show depicts in
reality it was Griselda and Marta who
worked together establishing griselda's
relationship with the meden cartel the
two were close friends and Marta would
often lend Griselda money it said that
briselda owed her upwards of $1.8
million and thus had her killed to erase
the debt a bit different from the show
where she falls off a couch and dies of
an overdose it's Jorge rivy aala
griselda's top enforcer who ends up
being the key to putting giselda away
for good or at least that's what the DEA
thinks rivy was set to take a plea deal
if he named Griselda as the masterm Mind
behind three counts of first-degree
murder but this fell apart after he was
caught having phone sex with two that's
right two secretaries in the State's
Attorney's Office although he was only
charged for three it's thought that rivy
killed dozens in his time working in the
drug trade at the same time Dario flees
to Colombia with his son Michael in 1983
grisela hired assassins dressed as
police officers and had him killed of
griselda's four children only one
Michael Corleone was still alive after
she finished 19 years in prison It is
believed that her first three children
were killed by the medine cartel as
revenge for the death of Marto choa
Griselda was ultimately released from
prison in 2004 on grounds of
compassionate release due to worsening
health issues she was deported back to
Colombia where she was shot by an
assassin in a motorcycle the same style
of killing giselda was known for in
Miami to this day her killer remains
unknown the final shut of the season is
her alone on the beach as her three
children fade away you may have noticed
that throughout the series Griselda does
this hand motion while holding a
cigarette this is her manifesting her
plans in prison she wants nothing more
than to be with her boys but because of
her life of crime she'll never get to be
with them ABC news reports that Griselda
was responsible for 40 murders in the US
and at least 250 in Colombia and these
are only the ones we know about but what
did you think of Griselda is it up there
with Naros or was the show too
melodramatic for your taste let me know
what you thought in the comments below
thanks for watching be sure to like And
subscribe and for more mad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
Daddy loves you very
much